so let's talk about the legal arguments
behind today's Supreme Court ruling and
more senior political analyst Brett Hume
joins us live tonight good evening Brits
your reaction to this ruling from well I
think it's you're correct when you
suggest that it's it's well it's not an
arrow vote it was 7 to 2 it is a rather
narrow holding in the sense that it
applies to an instance in which what the
court really found was that these that
this Baker didn't get a fair hearing
that the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission's were so biased against him
and indeed a biased against they were
the Baker's religious convictions in
fact it belittled those convictions in
one case describing that argument is
despicable
that it wasn't a fair hearing and
therefore it couldn't stand it does
however I think give some recognition of
the idea that religious convictions may
be a reason to deny services in certain
circumstances we don't know yet from
this exactly what all those
circumstances might be maybe the case of
the florists will tell us more that
probably should enlighten if they decide
to take it they'll need four votes to do
that on Thursday okay to the other legal
issues now the president and whether or
not he can pardon himself the
Constitution itself doesn't say anything
about that but he's getting a warning
from one of his own top lawyers he is
that Rudy Giuliani was saying yesterday
and what a lot of people got outraged by
the President had the authority to
pardon himself but it would be a
disastrous step would almost certainly
lead to impeachment and of course he
also pointed out that if he did pardon
himself the pardons don't apply to
impeachment and and this this question
of whether he could pardoned himself it
remains an open question in the sense
that the pardon power is pretty sweeping
the president can exercise it pretty
much as he sees fit
however it has never never been
exercised that anybody knows of in a
case where a person is pardoning or a
president is pardoning himself and the
Constitution is basically solid on that
there is a principle in the law that we
all kind of recognize which is that no
person shall be the judge of his/her own
her own case and this would seem to fly
in the face of that so it's a doubtful
proposition that he could actually
pardoned himself it goes along with that
advice that you shouldn't be your own
lawyer either or you have a fool for a
client so you can't be your own judge
you can't be your own lawyer by some
estimations but also there's this issue
of this 1974 decision came from within a
legal opinion within the Department of
Justice this goes to the question of
whether
president could be indicted by robert
muller and in in the Nixon era and I get
73 or 74 the Justice Department Office
of Legal Counsel which is the Justice
Department's in-house attorney
determined that you that a president
could not be sitting sitting president
could not be indicted that was looked at
again in 2000 by the same Office of
Legal Counsel obviously different people
came to the same conclusion Justice
Department of legal opinions like that
are not binding law they are however
binding on the department and since
Robert Muller is a creature of that
Department he's not an Independent
Counsel he's a Special Counsel working
for the Justice Department presumably
with those opinions we would be binding
upon him that does not mean however that
if the president was determined by the
Special Counsel to have committed some
crime that that he for which he could be
impeached he could then be indicted so
in other words if he was founder of
obstructed justice impeached
once he's impeached he's not in office
anymore that opinion doesn't apply
anymore he could be indicted tried
convicted yeah to those on the Left who
are raising hue and cry this weekend
saying he's an imperialist he's going to
do everything for himself he's going to
pardon himself the the Constitution
wisely provides them that impeachment is
the argument is being made now that the
president is declaring himself above the
law but impeachment is a core part of
our law and so long as he is vulnerable
susceptible to impeachment subject to
impeachment he's certainly not above the
law and both he and his attorneys
maintain this is a moot question he
won't need a pardon himself because he's
done nothing wrong and they're confident
that that is what the special case I
think the self pardon is kind of a it's
kind of a silly issue I don't think it's
going to happen and it would be
politically and could be calamitous libo
calamitous politically for him to try it
I think it was the the chair of the
Senate Judiciary Committee at Chuck
Grassley who just moments ago said I
would fire my lawyer if they finds me to
pardon myself so what advice probably
good advice Brett thank you for joining
us Jeff